bring in chad wolfe former acting
homeland security secretary to talk more
about this
um first of all let's just talk about
the immigration
crisis as a whole john saki actually
won't even address it as an actual
crisis
nancy pelosi calls it a humanitarian
crisis it seems that they just can't get
their vocab
to mesh but never mind what you call it
it doesn't matter the point is
it is indeed a crisis and kamala harris
where is she she's supposed to be
looking at the root cause of it right
that's what she was
that was the job she was given so where
is kamala harris in all this
well you're absolutely right and whether
you called a crisis or a challenge
the reality is we are seeing historic
numbers on that southwest border
of the legal apprehensions of minors of
families most of those being released
into the u.s
it's overwhelming the border patrol it's
overwhelming dhs and it's overwhelming
local communities so
any way you cut it there's a crisis
going on at the border it doesn't seem
to be ending any time in sight
because we know the biden administration
right now is not pursuing
any policies that will stem the flow of
these individuals coming into the
country and of course you showed that
video
of those two uh young girls being thrown
over
a border fence that is the direct result
of
this administration advertising that it
is okay
that they will continue to allow minors
to stay in the country if they arrive at
the border it is an inhumane policy and
we are seeing the results of that
i mean the video is just horrifying
i mean the the two little girl toddlers
are
plopped down onto our side of the border
there is the agent who rescued these two
little girls now they have no family
and they are now going to join the some
5767 children
uh in customs and border patrol uh con
custody as of just this past sunday and
those numbers
are skyrocketing in fact cnn is
reporting that the us is on track to
record
two million migrants on the southern
border by the end of the year
what is the plan to make it stop forget
the
the the focus on the root of the cause
how about just
the solution that's just it
again i've said that the administration
continues to address this issue as
though it's a capacity issue
trying to bring on more facilities and
uh
facilitating the introduction of these
individuals into the country
and that is the wrong approach you've
got to address the illegal behavior
that's happening at that border
to stop the flow to stop the the tide
uh that is coming in and the surge that
is coming in so that's really where they
need to be focused it's not where
they're focused today
so i urge them to change course in doing
that but again you talked about
the miners there's over 5000 about 5 000
in custody cbp custody another 7 or 8
000 in hhs custody and for dhs
that's almost double what we saw in the
height of the crisis in 2019 when
so many on the far left and others were
so outraged at what was going on in the
border they have doubled the amount of
minors in cbp facilities today
and then again it's a direct result of
these policies that they have been
pursuing since inauguration day there
are ways to fix this
right and border patrol and dhs can stun
the tide very very quickly
chad i want to talk to you about another
growing crisis and uh it's a new fox
news uh analysis
which shows that crime surging in
democrat-led cities
that slashed police funding last year
this is an issue murders
up 46 percent in minneapolis 271 percent
in portland oregon
12 percent here in new york city 28 in
los angeles
and in los angeles county more
controversy around new district attorney
george
gascon who critics call pro-criminal
sources reportedly saying that he's
planning to downsize
and rename the city's hardcore gang unit
the sister of a man killed by a gang
member
speaking here this morning watch i just
can't believe that he's actually making
this action
it was actually the work of the gang
unit and the hardcore
gang unit in the da's office that really
kind of pull this case together
it is really unfortunate because these
gangs in la streets are very very real
and they're very very dangerous
quite often which is in the case of my
brother innocent people are caught in
the crossfire of
this gang activity i mean this is no
surprise an uptick in crime when
different democratic-led counties are
reducing their
budgets for police i mean what did they
expect was going to happen that all the
criminals were going to go into hiding
well this is exactly what we talked
about last summer when this big push to
defund the police
and really to look closely at police
procedures what we did in the trump
administration is we came out with a set
of reform
principles that we could we believe that
the law enforcement community could back
and they did
but what we saw from the left again is
going very much beyond that and going to
defund the police
take down gang units and and other
measures and we see the dramatic
and detrimental effects that that is
having and we see places like
minneapolis
and portland that have now trying to
retract some of the
measures that they took over the summer
uh but it's it's certainly not working
and some of these big cities
that have this approach whether it's
seattle minneapolis portland or
there's three or four others um they're
going in the wrong direction they're
going in the wrong direction and
and they need to take a playbook out of
those other large cities
uh that have made uh police reform
not only prosperous in the sense of
making sure that you're bringing in more
resources you're providing the
leadership and the training
to police here's what i wanted in a very
productive way i want to know what the
where the biden administration stands in
all of this because you remember there
was sort of a back and forth about
whether
joe biden during the election um
supported to fund the police
movement or didn't um and he did come
forward finally after a lot of pressure
because he was silent on it for quite
some time
and said that he did not support to fund
the police but he however thought that
each city or each county needed to deal
with it on its own but
at what point does the biden
administration stand up and tell these
counties look
this is not the time to be slashing
budgets
if there has ever been a time to get
behind the men and women in blue
protecting our country and our innocent
civilians the time is now
well you're exactly right the president
has largest microphone
out there when he speaks uh or
members of his administration speak some
folks do listen and so they need to come
out they need to support the men and
women in blue
they need to back law enforcement
because at the end of the day
these are the individuals that put their
lives on the line to protect our
communities
big and small and they need to have the
backing of their commander-in-chief they
need to have the backing of the
president
and every day and every week that he's
silent he doesn't talk about this and we
see
you know news in portland they are still
targeting federal facilities and federal
agents in portland today
and again the administration is silent
on that it seems as though they only
want to talk about the events of january
6th right
here in d.c but if there's a violence
towards other federal officers or
facilities
they don't want to talk about it i
always say silence speaks volumes chad
wolf thank you very much for talking to
us